there's a lot of style over substance
within AR or any innovative technology
like VR as well why are we doing it is
it going to benefit the user in long
term or is there another way of doing
this that's equally easy and that
they're more familiar with and they're
more likely to to interact with so we've
got an open kind of generic dell
computer in front of us now i have
created a 3d tracking model and using
augmented reality we can superimpose
information in this case it's the riser
card cage that it shows the user how to
pull out you have to flick the switch at
the bottom and pull that out if you need
to replace any of the components within
the motherboard so I've just opened up
the AR app and you can see that it snaps
to the different elements in the 3d
object we have in front of us and you
can see at the bottom it has an
animation about how a user would go
about pulling out the riser card cage at
the bottom and this can be a linear
experience it can be an experience where
the user has control of different use
cases where they'd have a variety of
different computers in front of them yes
it's already been used kind of in
industry and it's starting to be used
within education so you've got the AR
layer which essentially is initializing
the experience bringing up the models
etc and then you can add an html5 layer
on the top of it which can incorporate
more front user front led functionality
such as being able to use gestures and
freezing the screen that sort of thing
and that's using javascript base library
on top of the AR environment so it kind
of adds a bit more value to the our
experience rather than just showing
something pretty it allows the user to
interact with it and get what they want
from it this is like using image
recognition so a simple image that's
been printed out and this is a small
area of Greenwich in London and the
information originally came from quite a
large data set
surrounding geospatial information in
the area of Greenwich in London and
through kind of 3d mapping we're able to
interpret the land use whether it's
residential and which business areas the
area vegetation around the mapping
itself we can switch the different
layers this gives the user quite
interactive potential in that they can
turn the gestures on they can scale it
up they can turn it around they can move
it away they can freeze the tracking
which I guess a lot of students and
users will want to do because holding up
a device isn't really great user
experience so it must be hurting your
hand holding up yeah it is that surely
one of the issues with doing this is
holding the device yeah and one of the
issues is you know having to hold it in
front of the environment or the image
but you can overcome that by using
functionality that you can employ to
freeze the tracking and then you're able
to take it away you may have a group of
friends that you want to interact with
an image and it's a lot easier being
around a table looking at a static image
where you're not forced to to hold the
the iPad or device up in front of you so
being able to take it away from that
initial tracking and then messing around
with it and rotating it and doing loads
of things with it so we've got here a
twin tower and you're putting a device
ative wall still judging just not having
the print out the first base and just
having the device one why would you use
a are in this instance rather than just
I guess it's more of a immersive
experience it engages the user a lot
more because they're part of that
experience whereas if you imagine a
lecturer in a theater speaking to a
large class they're quite disconnected
from the knowledge transfer here they're
part of this learning experience they're
engaging with something that they can
see it's very visual they can interact
with the environment in front of them
more than they would if they were just
taking notes or visiting a website or
even messing around with a CAD model
in a piece of software I've got asked
the question is it sure Lisa's is a
gimmick is there I think in a lot of
cases and I think that's one of our and
any new kind of innovative technology
shortfall is that the the money tends to
be surrounding marketing and advertising
and that's what is projected into the
mainstream media so a lot of the
detractors will say yes it's great this
this advertising campaign is great for
the first time that someone watches it
but what is the the worth past that
experienced users will all visitors will
not really go back to it in the future
so i think when i create anything to do
with AR it has to be quite immersive but
it also has to have quite a long shelf
life users have to return to it and gain
valuable insight which they couldn't do
in a five-second advert like any
learning resource it needs to be
something that's less of a gimmick and
more tangible in terms of a good use of
their time because students are probably
the biggest critics when it comes to any
new technology they will immediately
switch off if they can't see the value
in it or if it's replicating something
that they could already get quite easily
Hollywood is depicting Bob vision they
are we watch something like I a man or
whatever and you're gonna have you know
a heads up displays and all this sort
yeah how close is actual reality things
like Microsoft sir new announcement any
sort of IT company are always trying to
push the boundaries and it's about
managing expectations I think if the
users have an expectation that they can
go into a holodeck like star star trek
generations and be completely immersed
is probably not realistic and one of the
issues at the moment is the hardware is
kind of holding back the innovation so
there's great ideas that are out there
but it's just a hardware for instance 3d
models anything over about 20,000
polygons in a 3d model and it will crush
the app and that's detrimental to to
mainstream adoption I think so if you
had a user experience where the user is
going to become frustrated it's not
going to work effectively
I think we're a long way from what the
hollow lens predicts will be something
that will interact with on a daily basis
mention a certain amount of polygons so
go back to that of you you have their of
Greenwich yeah polygons is something
like that showing I think there's about
between five and ten thousand polygons
but the original area that I wanted to
deal with was millions so having quickly
learned that that doesn't translate into
a mobile a good learning experience for
a mobile environment and you have to
manage your expectation and if that
means like limiting the amount of
polygons maybe the 3d models won't be as
photorealistic as you want them but in
terms of the learning experience will be
a lot more robust so you can create any
color you like on your monitor by
varying the different amounts of these
three colors on a printer we work in a
completely different way so we're not
talking about light anymore we're
talking about ink